well back in Washington Attorney General
William Barr faces backlash from
hundreds of former Justice Department
officials for reversing a sentencing
recommendation for mr. Trump's longtime
friend and Ally Roger stone Paula Reed
is at the White House Paula is the
Attorney General's job in jeopardy a
good morning jurika there's no
indication that the Attorney General
will be out of a job anytime soon but
the Justice Department is facing a
crisis of confidence in a letter
released over the weekend over 1,100
former justice officials who've worked
in both Republican and Democratic
administrations called vars decision to
intervene in the Roger stone case a
grave threat to the fair administration
of justice the Attorney General says the
president has never asked him to do
anything in a criminal case but CBS News
has learned that Boris relationship with
the rank-and-file is increasingly
strained and it's not just about his
intervention in the stone case but also
this unusual trend of tapping his US
attorneys to review or reinvestigate
matters of significant interest to
president Trump and this includes the
evidence that Rudy Giuliani is gathered
in Ukraine the origins of the Russia
probe and most recently the prosecution
of the president's former national
security adviser Mike Flint the
president has been vocal about his
support for Flynn and CBS News has
learned that the president is pleased
that Barr has decided to review this
case and overall the president is quite
happy with vars performance in his job
Tony
Paula read for us Paula thank you very
much